uh my name is Nico yosotis you might
have heard my name
um I'm currently writing a book about C
plus 20. it's almost done only 700 pages
just 20.
and I have a chance to talk one hour
about my favorite examples
other favorite examples always good
so nice no
you will also see some traps oh I'm not
allowed to say traps
I have to say pitfalls
because these traps were not intended
well
some things were intended by Design
but uh
for a good reason
so let's see what we have
let's start with Concepts and ranges
assume
you have want to implement a simple
function
a simple function that adds a value into
collection a generic function
so any collection can be used any value
can be used as long as things compile
um here we use pushback
so which means it will only work for
collections that support pushback so
um calling this for vector
and and you push in a value that fits
like here
42 it's a vector of end
works fine
good
there's a new way to write that
the way you can write that as
that you declare the parameters to be
Auto
this converts a function into a function
template it's not a function anymore
it's a function template
it's just a new shorter syntax
to implement
function templates so it's a it's a
shortcut for the thing on the right
except that the thing on the right has a
name for t
or T1 and T2
y the thing on the left has no name
for the type
T1 and T2 the type that auto represents
as it is the function templates all
rules apply as before for our function
templates usually you put that in header
fights also the definition and header
height you don't need inline to declare
in a header file
yeah that's it
good
well this does not work everywhere
so let's overload it with another
function template
calling inset
um that should be used for containers
that don't have pushback but support
insert
unfortunately nothing compiles anymore
what
overload resolution kicks in overload
resolution says um
I have to decide what to call there are
two ad functions they don't look the
compiler does not look at the body so
all it looks at is
um the Declaration the Declarations are
the same return type is ignored by the
way
so there's no rule to prefer one over
the other so the compiler says this is
ambiguous
okay how can we solve that
well
stop making then ambiguous
give them different signatures
there were very to do that one of the
most nasty way or nastiest ways we have
is enable this
was used in Abel if in the past
who likes it
you are fired
nobody can like it because it creates
unreadable code
kidding
um
that's a better way now to do that
the better way is
place a constraint
to the Declaration
so here the constraint we use here is
has pushback
so the collection
[Music]
we pass which is still generic that's
why you use Auto here you cannot skip
out here
has a type constraint
um it has the support push back where it
comes this magically has pushback from
where from
well this is what we have introduced in
C plus 20 a concept
so you can define a concept concept is
not for code generation
concept is to decide whether something
can be called or not whether something
is available or not
so here we Define that has pushback
specifies that has pushback is satisfied
are met
if
pushback can be called
for a value type of this collection so
as you see on the right that's what we
call a requirements expression we
formalize requirements here
well there's an implicit requirement our
type we pass our type
call has to has a member value type
um and there's an explicit requirement
for this value type we have to be able
to call pushback
to put it in the container
so three things work together on the
right you have requirements on the left
you have a name for these requirements
and you use them to constrain your
generic code these three terms
you have to carefully not mix them
okay
that's it and you know what it compiles
both compile the effect is that
well if a container does not support
pushback the first template is not
visible
so only the second one is visible
so that's the case if we use a set of n
so we call insert
but for a vector both are visible
because we have not constrained the
second one
um but there's a rule
the first one is more specialized
than the second one
and that uh sorry
and that means
that this is preferred for vector so the
vector will call that
which is the right thing
again note that this is equivalent that
you use a generic code using template
syntax there you could qualify the
template parameter directly with has
pushback has the same effect but you
have a name now for it
and please note one more thing a little
tiny thing here
um if you look on the top right
call colon colon value type so what we
learned sometimes the hard way is if
there's a template parameter and you
have a member that is a type you need
type name
do you do you see type name here anymore
no because in some places well
everywhere where it's clear that it's
member has to be a type
this type name is no longer necessary
one place as this
in C plus 20.
good
you can write this code in different
ways so another way to write it is to
say oh let's uh formulate the
requirement not to qualify the
type of the first parameter let's
formulate the requirement well this is
not a requirement this is a constraint
we use the request keyword for two
things formulate requirements that what
we do on the top right
formal light constraints
that's what we do in the middle left
so we constrain that the type of collect
of call has pushed back
so we can use Auto here
oh you can combine this requirement with
other requirements
so I require this and that and that and
that
that is why you can also use this syntax
oh but wait a minute
this does not compile
for vectors
you get a crazy error message the error
messages I cannot call insert for 42 in
a vector
which means the first one is not
available
foreign
yes so what you call here is Vector
reference colon colon value type
that's not valid code well that's not an
error because requirements work the way
if code is not valid the requirement is
not met
so we don't see this template we only
see the second one for Vector in this
case
yeah
okay well things are not that easy
well and one way to remove that is to
fix that is to say let's remove constant
referenceness from this type we have a
new type trade for that a type function
um because so often we just needed that
remove referenceness and Constance and
maybe volatan as that's a new one
and then it works fine but maybe it's
better
to do the work to make the concept more
flexible and to do that
um you can put it in the concept so you
can cite and say instead of qualifying
the type
and then going to the member value type
let's use a helper function a new helper
function of C plus 20. that helps to
deal with ranges and there are types
which has stood rangeless value type
which will even deal with references for
that you need edify
can be formulate this differently yes of
course everything you can form like in
1000 ways in C plus plus even simple
examples
so instead of doing that because this
requires that the type on the right
the type of the value we'll put in has
the same type as the collection so that
would mean we don't support support
implicit type conversions
uh let's do something better let's use
not has pushback let's use can pushback
can push back now takes two template
parameters one is a collection one is a
template parameter the type of the value
and um here we don't need any references
because we can directly formulate it
what we want to have we want to have
support that you can push back the value
into the collection please note again a
requirement a constraint a concept is
not generated code
so there's no need to declare the
parameters in the required expression
with be a reference
yeah it's fine to make them values
because nothing this is only to clarify
whether things should other things
should compile
good
again if you if you if you really like
to you to use Auto you can do it that
way you can also put the requires Clause
after or at the end of a declaration by
the way this even works for member
functions
in class templates
and that way
here you can say give me the type of the
collection give me the type of the value
we already have names for them so we
pass them over and formulate this thing
we can formulate this thing with with
other constraints which we um add
by combining and also in the requires
clause
different ways to formal light
requirements
perform like constraints I should say
but also different ways to form light
requirements and Concepts
so forget that
don't do that
this is a bad example
you should not
use the concept for each and every
member function you use in your code
if we would do that we would have
requirements for big functions where we
have oh does it support pushback does it
support size does it support and the
star operator does it support that the
star operator Returns the Boolean value
and so on you would uh just more or less
mirror all the statements in your
requires class so as a constraint
so don't do that
just
create more cost grained
concept
we've done that in the C plus standard
for you so you can benefit from that we
will see that in a moment but as I said
do do that
what you see here but this is so cool
if pushback is supported that's called
pushback otherwise let's call insert
so do we have an alternative yes
formulate the requirement at Hawk
where you need the constraint either as
a constraint this is funny this is
requires requires in your code
but please remember what you learned One
requirement is for class for an
expression for
a defines a requirement that the inner
requires us to formulate the requirement
and the other request is to say I want
to have this as a constraint for my code
now it makes sense you just read the
example you say we are all silly
no we are not
and we like to reuse keywords for
different things
because each new keyword breaks code
is there a better way to do that
well remember that the signature is the
same for both ads so the difference is
only in the body of the function
so um
there are some rules the a rule is a
requirement
is a Boolean value a compile time
Boolean value
a constraint checks for compile time
Boolean value a concept is a name for
compile time Boolean value you can use
it like a cons expert Google
so we can do the following
we have a compiled time is
so in the body we say if the pushback is
supported call it otherwise call insert
nice
it's almost reflection
not really but
it's okay I know how often I have I want
things like that
good
um yeah
oh let's let's make something wrong
let's pass a string
oh let's declare that the elements are
strings and passing it you see the arrow
on the bottom
so you have so far seen that concepts
are used
um to decide which function should be
used to fix overload resolution whether
a function is available but there's
another reason we have that and that is
to make error messages more readable
because you find problems in your code
when you call it not deep in the Deep
darkness of your code
so um if you do things like that you get
a crazy Arrow message
yeah there's something broken
well oh yeah in line 500 or 600 of the
implementation of a set we have a
problem
um
we have no known conversion from
constant to const yeah
okay
so yeah I I'm pretty sure you have seen
error messages when using templates
which are not understandable
or what you understand once you have
once you have found the error it should
be the other way around
um
so
can we can we benefit from that
well here's the error message sorry
I'm always a little bit behind because I
I see the next slide here and I forget
that you not see the next slide yet
okay
good
yes
final light
constraint
formulate the constraint that the value
we want to insert with pushback or
insert is convertible to the element
type of the container
that's it and here you use a standard
concept
by the way we also use here cut style of
the concept to say the collection has to
be arranged so that we don't call it for
an end
and that we get early error messages
here here in the Declaration in the
Declaration we see that some
precondition is broken
and so the error message could now be
something like this yes there's a
problem with that but the candidate
template is ignored because the
constraint is not satisfied and the
constraint that is not satisfied is that
convertible to
um evaluated to false
by the way compilers are working on good
error messages with broken constraints
currently in visual C plus
the messages a constraint is broken
you have no idea which you have no idea
why
they are working on that
so if you see this video
later than in summer 2022 it's not a
problem anymore I promise I hope I can
promise
good you might even find some details
good
okay what time is it
good favorite examples let's now use
these examples so
um
now let's use this benefit from that in
ranges and Views a library we can use
um to uh that uses Concepts a lot
and here's what the library can do
instead of calling sort for begin and
end
you can now do what you have dreamed
about for 20 years you can call past
your collection as a whole to sort
and unfortunately you need a different
namespace for some conflicts we have
yeah back for compatibility as a
nightmare and it gets worse and worse
and um
yeah but now
um you can pass the thing as a whole and
the good thing is
this library that now takes the range as
a whole
uses Concepts
so the Declaration of this sort says for
example the range must be a random
access range
so a range where we can jump back and
forth
to modify the elements and that uh the
iterators of this type have to support
sortability
however this is supported for example
less than has to be so oh they the the
Sorting has to be able to be used for
these elements
so you get here again better error
messages when you now use
this
libraries
so let's Implement print
takes an input range we want to iterate
once of all the elements that's the way
we can write it now
we can pass a vector we can print the
collection awesome
well
here it is here's a code
it's an input range
declared
with input range Auto
Vector print call and if you want to
pass a set of end
it works
with Rangers there comes another nice
feature which is
views
so that's the part now
to deal with a part of a collection or
with the elements or the values
transferred somehow
so you can say for example
um let's print only
the first three elements of this
collection
we have a view for that well we have a
function that creates a view for that
that says just go to the collection take
the first three elements that's it
and it works for both great
there's an alternative syntax you will
like it
it looks like that
take the collection pipe it into a take
View
so let the take view filters the
elements that only the first three of
them are taken and it works for both
awesome
a lot of filters we have
we can filter
and not just drop some elements but
elements that
don't fulfill a certain Criterion or we
filter them out or you can do that take
the first three elements take the value
we then have transform it to convert it
to a string append an s and that should
be printed to a generic print function
nice
who has done that already we've seen
that already
oh only a few yeah
we even support
Sentinels Sentinels is iterators and
iterators
and these in the end iterators can have
different types now so you can do
something like this you can say
um look at that I have a vector
and I want to print
all elements from the first from the
second element so I initialize this is
also a view a sub ring
with the second the position of the
second element and the end should be an
end value
the end value is -1
what the hell is that
well
you can now print it and you get these
elements you can pass this to take and
transform and you get these elements up
to minus uh one as
as printed
the output is wrong is it
there's an there's an 11 missing
back on the slide
so 11s is missing
um what is end element this is end
element this is all you need yeah
oh it's not missing because of the takes
three yeah you're right thank you
yeah I'm
I'm Ill yeah thank you I just wanted to
find out whether somebody sees it
um
are you
so end value
um
has a surprising short implementation
it's a it's an end value uh where we we
can pass a value that ends
the iteration
and it has only a comparison operator so
we can compare it with and the thing
that is a parameter is a is a iterator
so we can compare with the parameter
by looking at the value of this iterator
and looking at our value and if both are
equal
then yes
we have a value equal to what we were
initialized with well what we were
declared with
because our value is declared part of
it's a template parameter
so that is enough why is that enough
well look at how the range space follow
works the range space follow initializes
to begin with what we passed initializes
the end with what we pass
these two things have different types
and then it iterates from begin to end
and it always compares the current
position with the end against the end
but using not equals hey we did we
didn't Define not equal we only defined
equally equal and the Order of the
operands is also wrong
but that's a new rule in C plus plus 20
and the C plus 20 rule says if a
compiler finds an expression like that
plus not equal end
it will rewrite and it it cannot resolve
it
then it the call will be Rewritten now
so we will use equal equal maybe with
the opposite order of the uh operands
and then apply not to that and that's
why this compiles
so he had another feature of C plus plus
11 at 20.
oh a little bit of a side note
um I used auto here
as when I declared n value
um and we have a new feature that is
auto so template parameters cannot be
data structures as long as they are
public so we can say okay here
um let's use a coordinate a data type
that has X Y and Z coordinate and let's
create a sub-range that goes from begin
to the end value with which is the
default initialize coordinate so with
the value of zero zero zero and that
works fine
enough enough of this
okay nope
I want to skip something so everything
is great isn't it great
[Music]
we can use begin and end of different
type we can use the novel containers we
can
print them out we can take the first
three elements uh and yes there are
other views we can drop the first three
elements of course and we can drop the
first three elements of a set of a list
and
oh
what
this does not compile
what the hell is going on here
why does this not compile we have 4
million programmers two millions of them
will run into this trap
this it works as design
I was one of the first
maybe I try this oh that works
what so I can call drop
but I cannot call drop as a parameter to
print
but I can call drop for different
container
what
the [__]
sorry in the US if you see that there
no it's not allowed to say that
that's the problem
drop
has an implementation detail
the implementation detail is
caches began
if again may become expensive
well begin for
a vector is not expensive
well the beginning of the drop so drop
has to ignore three elements so to
compute the begin of the drop yeah if
the underlying range is a vector we jump
to the fourth element easy
but if we have
something like a list
we have to iterate over all the leading
elements oh that's expensive maybe maybe
we need this view once again
well usually we do not but maybe we do
then begin should not iterate once again
to the to the first element that is fits
this View
so we can begin
cash and begin means while we are
iterating
we are modifying The View
so it cannot be const
the problem is that print takes and
makes the view const
because it declares a const reference
okay
what can we do
I want to pass it by reference so well
if you um remove cons you can no longer
pass temporary objects anymore
but we have another thing which is this
thing out to to ampersands or template
parameter to Ampersand which is called a
universal reference because it can
universally refer to um different L
values and R values temporary objects
and not in temporary objects objects
with a name and it does not make the
arguments const by the way the standard
committee decided to name this
forwarding reference which was a huge
mistake because they thought it's only
for forwarding in move semantics but
this is not for forwarding this is
because we need a reference that can
universally refer to everything the term
Universal reference was coined by Scott
Myers
I have no idea why the standard
committee was not happy with that term
it was better than forwarding reference
sometimes things like that happen
okay so this can universally refer to
everything not making it constant
suddenly it compacts
yay
so um that means for all your generic
code if you want to pass containers and
the end views
switch from const reference constellar
reference counts with one Ampersand to
cons to non-cons and two Ampersand easy
just take all your code and bake this
adoption
that's the question
is the view expensive to copy
oh we could have passed it by value and
what is with the first two statements
I want to use this function to print
containers
so if I want to pass a container
I have a problem
so
um
well there's a caveat here if you do
that if you make this fix
because they cache
that means that and this caching of
begin is not threat safe
if this function would use multiple
threats to iterate over the elements
don't do that
awesome design I think is it worth it no
it's not worth it it's just about
caching and most of the times we know
need to Cache the begin because we use
review only once
foreign
so yes we can use by value you propose
that but that would make calling print
for containers expensive there's another
workaround the workaround is um require
that it's an it is a cheap range a view
so and if you do that
um but then you can no longer pass a
container well there's a way to make a
container
a reference to a container which is also
a view we have which says take all the
elements of this container and give some
reference semantics and that is here
though that is what you would have to do
then
choose your best bad choice
I don't think this is good design
we come back to this in a in a moment
let's talk about threats multi-threading
different topic
so this was one example we come back
um let's randomly initially eyes some
values that are in a vector
so let's write this function
um
it takes all the values as a template
parameter so this is code before C plus
plus 20. we have to initialize a random
device to have random numbers and then
we iterate all the values and we add a
random value to them
awesome will work
so what we can improve now in C plus 20
is a few things first of all we can say
this code does not make sense if you can
only iterate once over this range
because you need to do it twice because
you want to deal with the values in the
vector then so let's declare that the
requirement is that what you pass here
as an argument is a range you can
iterate over multiple times which is a
forward break
then
we can also say there's a requirement
that the values are integral because we
compute an integral random value which
we add so
um that is a better requirement unless
so we avoid that error messages in the
middle of this code
good
let's use multiple threads
okay
the first thing we do we make this
iteration
Alanda
a helper function locally declared so we
use a Lambda
then let's create a vector of threads
and each thread calls this Lambda you
push it into the vector
and yeah that's it using stood thread
which we have standardized in C plus 11.
well almost everybody of you if they
have views to thread know that you can't
do it that way there are several issues
here the most important issue is you get
a column without calling join
before the destructor of the threats is
called so you have at the end to add a
loop that iterates over all the threads
and waits for the end
that by the way is a violation of the
raii principle
that we should automatically clean
things up
in the destructor
for some good reason but not the perfect
reason so
the problem is this code is still broken
for a couple of reasons one is if
there's an exception in the middle we
will not call come to the point where we
call join for each
threat so this will have a quarter
then it might be better to be able if
there is an exception to stop all these
threats maybe they run a long time
and then of course the worst thing is
you can't write
hey we have multiple threats that modify
the same elements in the past collection
that don't do that don't do that
so let's fix this up
first thing is use J thread that's a new
thread type in C plus 20 J stands for
joining the destructor will
automatically join
if you haven't done it yet
so that means this code has become more
exception safe
but there's more J thread has an option
um you can in your startup function or
Lambda add an parameter which is called
a stop token and if you do that then the
destructor will signal you stop
and you can process that in your code
you see in the loop where we iterate
over the values before we do something
we check our it was a stop requested
and if there is we stop processing
because the problem is if we have an
exception
we won't have immediate reaction
and that is done now with this code
because automatically the distractor
will not only call join
it will also be fought called join
called request stop which you can also
do manually by the way
so that makes your code
safer
but we still have concurrent rights to
the elements how do we fix that or do we
have to introduce
new taxes Etc oh no that's something
nice in C plus 20.
introduce a temporary Atomic make your
values temporarily Atomic by using what
we call an atomic reference
so here in this context this is a
context where we need
atomicity of the values when we access
them
we make the values Atomic before we
modify them
and after that
um yeah and all threads all a concurrent
access has to do that otherwise it does
not work but it does not mean that the
values are Atomic in general it's just
temporarily atomic
nice
I think so everything is fine
what time is it okay
that was second example we come back
calendar is in time zones
we have the Chrono Library since C plus
plus 11.
and now we have added some extensions
most extensions are about dates
calendars weekdays time zones Etc so the
next higher level of time points and
durations
so here's the code you can do
let's initialize the first day with the
31st of January in 2021
and the last day and these are all
different types this is using the
operator slash to combine for example a
year with an end and you but you get out
as a year month and if you then combine
it with an end you get a year month day
so it's a fully typed system here
that makes sure that you don't do
something not useful and the same as
with the last day here
and then that we can iterate from first
date to last day incrementing the month
and let's have a party
oh this is the output
oh there's no party
uh because
um
um February 31st that's not a valid date
we blindly add increment the month
that's how
for year month day adding a month works
so um can we do it better
yes
well first of all
you can write code that decides what to
do
so
um if the data is not okay if the data
is not valid this Library supports that
you say oh in that case let's take the
first of the next one the first day of
the next month here's how you program
that
um
the else part take the year of the month
and but use one and increment the whole
date by one month and let's have the
party then there good
there's another way to do it
let's iterate from the last day of
January 21
so that's a different type that's not a
year month day that's a year month day
last
so in that case the logic is if we then
increment things
um then the month we increment to the
last day of the next month and the next
month
so now we have that easier
oh and you don't like the output format
well we have a formatting Library
use it that way
if you want you can apply time zones so
you can say assume this is a local time
local date or with local time at um 18
hours and 30 minutes use account time
zone to print it out and maybe invite
the people in LA and so apply this to
another time zone and print it out and
you have
but you see what you have
could
I like this Library
yeah I didn't show you all the traps
that no not traps pitfalls there are a
few things you have to know if you use
it but in principle this is a great
Library Howard Hina the designer of
Chrono it's an awesome guy
hard
what time is it
okay
let's combine everything that was that's
nice let's combine everything
so Concepts
Rangers views
oh the Chrono Library oh multiple
threads
using J thread
and atomic references
let's combine everything
so at the end this is a talk about one
about the favorite C plus 20 example I
have
not the multiple
foreign
a minute
you remember
so we take a forward range we require
that the values are integral
uh um and then we have an init
HIPAA function locally so it's a it's a
Lambda for um I don't have enough size
on this slide so that's DOTA dot for
some
so the code that initializes a random
number generator
because multiple threats use that we use
Atomic references when we apply our
modification and then we use this
initialization in a loop that iterates
over multiple threads
no join is necessary at the end
once all the threads are done we call
the destructors and they will call join
and that's it
whoa let's create a map and in this map
we have dates so year month day
and
um
numbers
how many items did we sell
that day whatever this number means
how many visitors did we have in our
Cinema
I don't know
yeah
so your key
it's a day
your value is
the value that applies to this day
makes sense huh I hope say yes please
good uh let's initialize it with some
values oh yeah we learned how to do that
um let's start with the last day of
January
um and let's just take all the last days
of the year so start with the last day
um up for all the whole year 2021
for each month and in place a new value
there with this date and the starting
value is zero so let's initialize this
container
and now yeah let's
more let's uh simulate selling so we
call random in it
and
there is a view that takes from a pair
the value
so from a key value pair the value this
view is called values
so we pipe the elements we take all the
elements we take only the values of them
and but this is an error
oh too bad I thought this it would be
have been cool
if this would have worked
what is the Arrow by the way do they
know that
I have 10 minutes left to see error
laughs
yeah thank you
um what is the era
so we don't wait 10 minutes
um
this creates a temporary object
and what we take it's a
Auto reference
it's not allowed
to have a non-conscious reference refer
to a temporary object or to an R value
but anyway we have
when we iterate about something that
might be a view
or container
yeah so
make it a universal reference and it
compines yes
so here's the output when we iterate
only over the values again using
this um
a view
so yeah we can also now iterate over the
elements
printing the date and the values here we
only print the values that's okay using
this pipe semantics for views
let's um oh um can we skip the
initialization of the first two elements
what do I have to do
hmm
drop yeah
call drop
does it work
yes
awesome done thank you for your
attention oh wait a minute there was
something
it works
with components it runs
do you know what
this is a runtime error
so who can tell me about the runtime
error is
too many elements now
this is a runtime error and we did a
designed
C plus was 20 that this kind of these
errors can occur
those who think this is a good design
say that
they don't see a problem here but this
is this is the consequence that this
code is broken
why
Timo you know that
you don't you have standardized that
yeah nobody in the salad committee knew
what they were voting on when they
accepted the proposal of Rangers and
views
it's a view problem
what did I tell you about that there is
a danger when you pass A View to a
universal reference
don't use multiple threats then
why
because the view is cache
so what you have here is you create a
view
this view is passed
to rent a minute
run a minute
starts three threads five threads they
all call For the First Time begin
and that is not threat safe
because it cash we cash the result of
begin in The View
so this code is broken
I have complained
the standard committee does not see my
complaint
let's make a threat saved version well
the problem is
you use a thread safe version of
something if you know that there's a
problem
ordinary programs will say yeah take
Works drop Works where's the problem
where is the problem
well we only have that because we cash
begin
and the price is that code like this is
broken
and we almost never need a cash to begin
because we should use views at Hawk only
once
if we would not cash
we could iterate overviews with const
if we would not cash we would not have
undefined Behavior
if somebody calls begin
why anotherly does that
is this the right design decision I
think not
so how can we fix this code
no I want to know something
my best advice to fix this code
it's absolutely ridiculous
because the problem of multiple threats
is inside
random in it
make sure we don't have a problem there
how do we do that
at the beginning of this function we
once call values dot begin
[Laughter]
and we don't have a problem anymore
yeah
there are a lot of people who hate me
because it looks like I make the
standard committee
look like a bunch of idiots no they're
not
they are smart people but sometimes we
make mistakes
and the problem is I think
caching in views was the severe mistake
and here you see why you might not agree
with me we can discuss that today or
over
over the sale in the evening I'm happy
to get some input
but I fear that problems like this we
will happen
I think this is not good design
maybe not very likely
but I I see the price of caching and
Views it's not worth
the benefit of caching
begin and Views is not worth the price
yep
is it possible to remove that caching
well
um strictly speaking we might break
existing programs because um you can
also do things like
um
um count on that that begin was cash
then insert on the underlying range new
elements at the front and then know that
drop now no longer works on the second
but on the third element
I would consider a code like that evil
but so I think yes we can fix that
because we would allow things that were
otherwise undefined Behavior I'm not
sure I want to propose that
because the standard committee is not
still not willing to fix the broken
range base for Loop
so they don't care for broken stuff if
they don't have the problem and they
don't have the problem because they are
experts they know
well they know but Timo did you know
that would you make this mistake
okay
that's it you have seen a lot of great
things
Concepts
that help you to um decide which code is
called
Concepts
to uh get early error messages
ranges and View support
views that helps you deal with
sub-ranges
um the Chrono library and improve the
fixed threat class
and temporarily Atomic types
what else have you seen oh the equality
operator can now be used for not equal
um
data structures can be template
parameters now non-type template
parameters
probably I missed a few things
so that's all what we have seen oh yeah
and Chrono calendar
and time zones what time zones yeah oh
no we saw time zones
formatted output with the format
function
you have not seen everything but that's
it and that's why this is my favorite
example because it's both
really nice but also a little bit
frightening
well you can say that's good tradition
in C plus
maybe it is
thank you very much
[Applause]